una ceremonia que termina con una firma
y el saludo del presidente con Los
líderes prorrusos de los territorios de
doñats lugano zaporiya y jerson Vladimir
Putin hizo oficial la anexión del 15%
del suelo ucraniano la mayor
incorporación en Europa desde la Segunda
Guerra Mundial
defenderemos nuestra tierra utilizando
todas las fuerzas y medios a nuestra
disposición y haremos todo lo posible
para proteger la seguridad de nuestro
pueblo esa es la gran misión liberadora
de nuestro pueblo el evento se produjo
durante una ceremonia en un salón
ornamentado acudieron funcionarios que
fueron testigos del mensaje de Putin a
Ucrania hacemos un llamado al régimen de
kiev para que deje de disparar y detenga
todas las actividades militares de
inmediato y también contra occidente
la destrucción de la hegemonía
occidental que ha comenzado es
Irreversible lo repito de nuevo ya no
será como antes
desde occidente rechazo ante la ane el
anuncio de sanciones Estados Unidos
castigó a mil rusos y aseguró que el g7
sancionará los países que apoyen la
secesión la Unión Europea apoyó a
Ucrania
la Unión Europea rechaza inequívocamente
y condena estas ilegales anexiones y
nunca las reconocerá como no lo hizo con
crimen en 2014
y desde Ucrania otra firma la de su
presidente bolodimir cellensky Para
entrar en la otan
confiamos unos en otros nos ayudamos
unos a otros Y nos protegemos unos a
otros Esto es lo que es la alianza hoy
Ucrania está solicitando hacerlo de
facto y acá precisamente zelenski se
reunió con los líderes militares para
estudiar los próximos pasos en cuatro
regiones que pese a la anexión siguen en